so I've seen the first six episodes of
season two my big complaint is I have
not seen seven through ten so I need you
guys to work on that
um
you both get to do cool stuff this
season what are you allowed to say oh I
guess not much but since you've seen the
episodes one through six I mean uh
playing Spock as a full human uh was
really a blast and Incredibly
challenging and uh and that was a really
great moment for me
um and I'll say that you know I'm just
glad we got to see Kirk
um sort of in the timeline that we all
know as Canon and I you know it's we we
sort of met him in this alternate
version in season one and I felt that in
season two I was able to sort of bring
out some of the qualities that are um
that we all know Paul I I know that you
guys are always trapped on set and you
can't wear costumes when you leave blah
blah blah so what was it like being in
downtown Toronto uh being able to fully
walk around and you know in costume and
you could walk into Starbucks and you
can't get in any trouble
um I loved it and and it was a real uh
homage to the city on the edge of
forever
um which is my favorite Trek episode
um although if I recall they did these
clothes fairly quickly but then again so
it
quickly as well um I loved it I love
those kind of sort of
you know
isolated uh one location type episodes
where you know we're on Earth and and we
got to sort of it was our playground
um I loved it and it was sort of a
singular episode and it was uh it was so
much fun I had such a good time filming
it I would have loved to I've been to
Toronto many times I would have loved to
have seen you guys filming I knew
exactly where you were and I'm like for
people that are fans they must have been
like wow you know because it's right
there
um you know yeah even I definitely want
to talk about you playing uh Spock as
human because you know on the weekends
you obviously you know you're getting
ready for the following week and you you
know you have spocked down but now all
of a sudden they're throwing on okay
Spock as a full human so what was it
like for you prepping for those scenes
because it definitely is more rehearsal
more how am I gonna do this yeah the
writers definitely have thrown me a lot
of spear balls which is really fun uh
you know what comes to mind for me in
season one is spot them up when I have
to play Spot playing to bring things why
um and this season yeah he wakes up all
screwed up
um human only but with the life
experience and an inner world of spunk
and I imagined that it was sort of like
being on some sort of uh drug trip right
he's like in an altered state of mind
and just trying to adapt to his new
um ability to perceive his new
um sensory perception right because
suddenly you don't have that uh
hypological half of you sort of clamping
down on your emotions and I saw it as a
great opportunity to
um be sort of childlike like Spock is a
as a human child kind of uh discovering
what it is like to be human fully for
both of you season's obviously 10
episodes uh do you have a favorite of
the ten episodes I mean I I'm I'm biased
the ones I was in you're in all of them
no I I I all jokes aside I I did truly
love working uh look I love moments from
all the episodes that I've done but um
if I had to pick one I did really love
episode three just driving fast cars and
sort of giving Kirk this sort of like
you know he was like a kid in a candy
store you know just running around to
Earth figuring it out for the first time
um you know obviously this is an
alternate again this is an alternate
timeline so it's just I I you know I had
it was just a blast yeah for me episode
five was just truly a joy to experience
as an actor I'm already given the
wrap-up signal I'm just gonna say
congrats on the season I really can't
wait to see the rest of the episodes and
you know hope it's a huge obviously does
incredibly well blah blah blah you know
what I mean thank you so much